now one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me it's work man they
say that the dictionaries only place you
see success before work and their self
medical I was ready to do myself in I
just couldn't handle the pressure
anymore from day one we knew how to play
every kind of music our entire business
is all based on two things a great song
a great story he's an American record
producer composer musician and
entertainment executive his career
spanned six decades in the entertainment
industry and he's been nominated for
record 79 Grammy Awards Time magazine
listed him as one of the most
influential jazz musicians of the 20th
century he's Quincy Jones and here is my
take on his top ten rules for success
rule number one is my personal favorite
I make sure to stick around all the way
to the end for some special bonus clips
number one is to know who you are and
learning to love who you are yes you
can't love anybody else if you don't
love yourself ray or not Charles Maggie
used to say every day in Seattle not one
drop of myself work depends on your
acceptance of me every day that was the
deal with racism with everything because
you don't want an external force
defining who the hell you are where have
you gone where to improve your arranging
skills as an arranger work where it
could study man where the study you know
I did that but I did that a long time
ago I put 28 years of my core skill and
orchestration counterpoint everything
because you got you know music is always
left and right brain intellect and
emotion and you've got to work to keep
the science gone you don't work to keep
the science gone you can't support the
emotion that million guys coming to tell
me man if I could play piano I could I
could be better Herbie Hancock I said
yeah but you doing a better Herbie
Hancock to see them works and all but
you have to work it's work man they say
that the diction there's only place you
see successful work and that's
alphabetical in school we were exposed
to March music and kind of classical
music and semi classical music and uh
at to make a living you had to play shot
ashes and all those things that
hospitals sold it was always the full
range of music around and I remember
once a child said to me we were trying
to put a bebop feeling and the shottish
is one time he said no he said you just
put your soul into the music you playing
your plan and let it be a shottish and
it'll be okay and I never forgot that
one KC Jones was stranded in Europe he
realized the importance of being a good
businessman as well as being a good
musician he had to really look at every
aspect of the business to try to get
home this is my responsibility I got him
over here and get him back I was ready
to do myself in I just couldn't handle
the pressure anymore because it was
performing and payrolls trying to book
and everything else no just I think when
people to think about taking their own
life it's not about it so it's just
about 15 minutes of peace get some rest
for a while it's amazing how it works
because a whole series of mistakes at
one point people start to call the
experienced boys very experienced in
that that means you had a chance to mess
up a lot and that's great because you
don't take any chances neither making
mistakes you know my father said to us
every day of our lives once the task has
just begun never leave it till it's done
be the laborer great a small do it well
or not at all every day of our life to
say that he would never let us have
stuff that I learned from him and I've
got treasured out you know because he
hasn't believed in doing anything
halfway
what advice do you have for the future
of making great records know what you're
doing
study everything it'll study music you
know because I was hearing some funny
stuff now that drove me crazy after some
of the producers today we were doing an
amazing project in
Rabat Morocco last year we had all of
the number-one singers in the Arab
Spring Libya Egypt Jordan Aleppo
Damascus everywhere and we're recording
over there I don't call no names over
there and I said do you read music
he said yeah I used to but I forgot give
me a break man
you forget how to read music but the man
you have to understand they put the work
in to learn the science man you do you
can't play a trumpet if you don't know
how to you know do you have it's a
science of armatures diaphragmatic
breathing there's a lot of Secrets with
everything you attempt to do you know
retrograde inversion the counterpoint
it's been just does that say there's
only 12 notes man so you can figure out
what you have to do to get your own
sound you have to do that through rhythm
melody and harmony and you have to do a
lot of research to figure that out you
know you have to know what's going on
get to understand I don't know
I've got prevail and Albert Bergen Basie
Duke and Bo Diddley and melly-mel and
Ludacris and Drake and all of me come on
man you know it's it's doing your
homework man that's all I can say
prepare yourself cuz my thing was I was
all my biggest fear and I don't play
with that word at all was to give a
great opportunity that I'm not prepared
for
so in Frank Sinatra call me man I was
ready for him I'm telling you and he
tests me he's really great Charles too
because those guys are rough man Billy
next time Ray Charles Frank synopsis
they will kick your booty you know and
he'd say to me in the first we don't
arrange to capital studios you say to
that first stage was a little dense no
problem man
and I put all the horns and trumpets and
Armin Meiwes full stems out transfer the
saxophones to the alto flutes and stuff
like let's go he was testing me I only
did it three times and after that he
said he knows what he's doing and now
because I was ready for it and that's
the biggest compliment man and
accomplishments you can have in your
life is to say I got my stuff together
together you have to have it together
man you do let me ask you about
creativity then and the diversity that
is Quincy Jones because I'm a kid of the
1980s so I know Quincy Jones the famous
guy the hit maker the pop wizard the R&B
soul guy you are a serious jazz guy
through the 50s I mean you're on tour
with Lionel hand on the understand man
yeah
from day one we knew how to play every
kind of music Sousa Davis's cherishes
but Bar Mitzvahs building rules
everything we'd played everything man I
got a lot of disses when I started doing
Michael Jackson I didn't have to learn
anything to do Michael
I mean been doing that all my life
that's my question no deep does the guy
who is the guy who toured with Count
Basie or did arrangements for Count
Basie and Gene Krupa Sarah Vaughan
that's the same guy who can produce hip
hop or pop music well we were doing it
all our lives it's the same didn't know
what naughty people on stage said Quincy
God gave us 12 notes did Bop Brahms
Beethoven Bo Diddley
they see bird all used the same 12 notes
until he gives us 13 I want you to know
what everybody did with 12 and I started
hard for 28 years man and there's not
for seven decades we never stopped them
we'd try to play like miles from play
like Charlie Parker like passing the
barrel and you and we need to come out
of that there's ten different people and
your personality is going to finally
have Stran Center not transcending that
but but morph into its own personality
because it's it is a personality and if
you have traveled the roads of all the
great people but I think that happens
with anything it's a camera man you know
you look at the saguaro whatever you
know all your favorite people in and and
and just deal with just the best or like
classical composers or whatever them or
people that deal with drama you know
what their elements from it they can say
I'll do it a different way
and jump into it jump all over it I'm
serious you know this the don't be
bashful jump into
try to copy it just like it is I mean I
mean I can't do this on a professional
level I mean in training your mind in
order to think on that level the highest
level go with everybody for Johnny
Williams a goldsmith you know to Alan
Silvestri
you know Stanley was telling me Clark
everybody I've wrapped seven kids I have
six daughters 21 to 60 that's why I
don't have any hair and one son but I
buy part of their tough love is to tell
them the first thing they have to know
is know who you are but there's a lot of
people don't know who they are and
that's very difficult but that's the
first challenge I think there's a know
who you are and if it's 70/30
work on it if the 30% stop whining and
move on you know and then after you know
who you are love who you are that's the
first two steps and that's what I've
monster to my children first you only
wait once you know who you are and I
love who you are you're on the way
because you don't love to do you are you
in trouble
we're on they've always been true to
yourself baby our entire business is all
based on two things a great song a great
story film television great if you don't
have that story nothing else matters you
don't call anybody else to direct any
money the same of the song great song
can make the worst thing in the world a
star but a bad song the three best
singers in the world cannot save it and
that's that's the bottom line now if you
are not working as a musician until the
later years of your life it doesn't
matter man it's 60 you can start man not
naughty palazzi told me that she said
you can become an attorney at 60 years
old man do whatever you feel like doing
if you're willing to put your mindset
behind it in the passion and the work
anything anytime in life seventy years
old I mean I feel like I'm just starting
man I really do
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Ari Gabriel
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Quincy's
top 10 rules had the biggest impact on
you and why leave in the comments I will
join in the discussion and lastly I want
to give a quick shout out to mark Drager
from Fanta media mark thank you so much
for buying one of my books it means a
lot to me for those of you watching if
you want to change at a shadow in a
future video make sure to pick up a copy
of the book and email in your receipt so
we can keep track thank you so much for
watching continue to believe or whatever
your one where it is and I'll see you
soon
it starts with a human being you know
that's a mighty big loss they said that
to me every day quantity or music can
never be more or less than you are as a
human being and that's what it's about
you know you can have all that science
and technique and everything else if you
don't have a life and love and live and
give us stuff like that you have nothing
to say you know to spread to share you
have nothing share to give them she's
right you know
man I've lived I'm not getting my best
you know that's a great Charles you can
basic miles but this is so not so please
it's not used to tell us every night we
got off the stand you live every day
like it's the last one one day you'd be
right